so there's the the story of uh newton
coming up with quite a few ideas uh
during a pandemic
we're uh on the outskirts of a pandemic
ourselves right and a lot of people use
that example as motivation for everybody
while they're in lockdown to get stuff
done
uh so
what's that about can you tell the story
of that
well i can let me first say that uh of
course we've been teaching over zoom
lately and there was no zoom back then
yeah there was no zoom back then
although it wouldn't have made much
difference because the story was newton
was so complicated in his lectures that
at one point the humphrey newton
actually said that he might as well have
just been lecturing to the walls because
nobody was there yeah
to listen to it so what difference but
uh also not a great teacher huh
i if you look at his optical notes
if that's what he's reading from oh boy
okay
no
so what uh what can you say about that
whole journey through the pandemic
that uh that resulted in so much
innovation right of amount of time well
now i mean there's two times that he
goes home
would he have been able to do it and do
do it if he'd stayed at cambridge i
think he would have
i don't think it really although i do
like to tell my advanced students when i
lecture on the history of physics to the
physics and chemistry students
especially we've been doing it over zoom
in the last year when we get to newton
and so on because these kids are you
know 21 22 i like to say well you know
when newton was your age
and he had to go home during an epidemic
do you know what he produced
so can you actually summarize this for
people who don't know how old was newton
and what did he produce
well newton goes up to cambridge as it
said when he's 18 years old in 1660
and the so-called miraculous year the
annus mirabi lease where you get the
development in the calculus and in
optical discoveries especially is 1666
right so he's what 24 years old
at the time but
judging from his
the notebooks that i mentioned he's
already before that come to an awful lot
of uh development
uh over the previous couple of years
uh
does it have much to do with the fact
that he twice went home
it is true
that the optical experiments that we
talked of a while ago with the light on
the wall moving up and down we're done
at home in fact you can visit the very
room he did it in to this day
yeah it's very cool and if you look
through the window in that room there is
an apple tree
out there in the garden so you might be
wrong about this i thought you were
lying to me what maybe there's an apple
involved after all well
it's not the same apple tree but it's
cuttings how do you know
they don't last that long but okay it's
400 years ago
oh wow i continue with the dumbest
questions okay so
you're saying that perhaps going home
was not
it may have given him an opportunity
to work things through and after all he
did make use of that room and he could
do things like put you know a shade over
the window move things around cut holes
in it and
do stuff probably in his rooms at
cambridge he maybe not although
when he stayed at cambridge
subsequently became a fellow and then
the first uh actually the second
lucasian professor there he was actually
really the first one because
isaac barrow
who was the mathematician professor of
optics recognized newton's genius gave
up what would have been his position
because he recognized
not newton may not have learned too much
from him although they did interact
and and so newton was the first lucasian
professor really the one that stephen
hawking held uh until he died um and we
know
that the rooms that he had there at
cambridge uh subsequently because rooms
are still there
he built an all chemical furnace outside
did all sorts of stuff in those rooms
uh and
don't forget you didn't have to do too
much
as lucasian professor every so often you
had to go give these lectures whether
anybody was there or not and deposit the
notes
uh you know for the future which is how
we have all those things
you